[Music]
and homeless man for rent news what
that's not right why would you want to
do that submitted my Falcon punch was a
video game smash bros all the smash bros
falcon yeah a homeless comedian makes a
good living by renting himself to people
for forty five cents a day in asia 45
cents yep who's not gonna do 50 yen yeah
that's that's different yeah 40 cent 45
cents what is that yes go math like
Whitley 931 a cold the fifteen dollar 50
cent am i doing the math right here no
that's 50 cents cuz you just move the
decimal over twice yeah fifteen dollars
and fifty cents
how are you gonna live off of that per
month no 50 young where is a four way
huh did you say 45 yen Oh 45 cents I
just rounded them I just rounded it to
5600k
again is 1/2 over that's look 50 cents
50 cents times 31 days which is a month
that's really weird
I'm thinking about like how do you
afford anything with $15 a month yeah
this guy's a genius
I feel like this might only work in
Japan though the way he did it so this
man his name is Kotani makoto and four
years ago he moved to tokyo to become a
comedian he ended up moving in with
another established comedian his name
was King Kong Nishino that's pretty cool
King Kong
sound like rims or something King Kong
machine Moschino and so his rent moving
with she know it was about can we calm
King Kong okay King Kong cuz I want to
imagine him living with King Kong on his
rent was about $400 a month
it's like 40,000 yen King Kong he
couldn't tolerate Kotani sloppy and
messy lifestyle anymore after a few
months its cardboard boxes everywhere
when he finally told him he was like
starting today you should become
homeless
your life will be definitely better that
way is what King Kong told Kotani so
then that's when Catania became homeless
Kotani and yes straight from that is
listen he was like you're right yeah so
he started sleeping on the street for a
while he had interviews but they didn't
really go that well at job interviews
and so that's when after some time
King Kong suggested that Kotani should
rent himself to total strangers for
forty five cents a day and so he did it
and he became really popular he ended up
building a fan base through social
social media with thousands of followers
Kotani family that's crazy and even
though like 50 yen a day isn't a lot his
clients do feel bad for him whenever
they read for him and they give him more
money or like they'll buy him food
clothes battle yeah they let him stay at
their place a lot of the times they
bought him a pocket Wi-Fi so he could
stay connected with his family or were
so nice you can do it here but at the
same time he's also working though
mm-hmm so it's like it's a little
different did this guy end up being more
successful than King Kong yeah oh let's
go look at their Instagram following
he's been chose everything that's a
validity right there [ __ ] I should have
talked to one homeless
over the last four years Kotani has been
rented over 1,000 times
he's extremely busy now so if you want
to hang out with him you have to book
him I Lisa a month in advance
let's see the website what's going on
here Instagram is what site they don't
push any is social media in this article
what does he do when you hire him you
just in the whole day he says that at
one point he was asked to be a nude
model to being sketched well it's like
he got rented out to stand in line for a
pair of sneakers not smart yeah things
like so those random odd jobs yes okay
because I thought they were hiring him
to be a comedian I tell jokes huh yeah
no like I think he even cleaned
someone's home once and just random
things like that but then he builds a
relationship with with his clients so
point where they continuously
so just like his personality yeah it
looks like a light-skinned Filipino yeah
no he looks like a cartoon character
oh yeah he looks like Waldo yes I feel
like it's name is r.j. or something
where does he get the are J Dilla Cruz
his fan yeah he's been buy him clothes
and like make sure that they all matches
if he's homeless where does he put his
stuff I know I was wondering the same
thing I think yeah oh maybe he sleeps in
those those those cafes and stuff at
night those don't cost too much yeah
they have lockers oh you mean those
capsule places no like there's this
looking like there's a what is it those
land center cafes and people sleeping he
looks harmless - yeah like I would
invite him over he doesn't seem like
someone that would like rape me in the
middle of the night mmm and after
hearing the story I'm like I want to
meet him he looks so fun I'm going next
month I'll find him for you guys yeah
document it are you gonna write on 15 50
cents
no I want to write on for like [ __ ]
just give him 30 bucks for a dance coach
oh yeah I don't have to pay I'm pretty
good he might actually be a really good
local tour guide - yeah he speaks
English that's [ __ ] money right Gina
you gotta make it happen right I'm gonna
find they did plug in one social media
account which is his Twitter it's cooked
any mikoto mmm he has 10k followers yeah
that's pretty good so he was already
kind of famous or like kind of he built
this up over four years so he was a
comic that no one knew like he was a
struggling comic yeah he just started
renting himself out I wonder how he got
the word out like this he's yelling the
side of the road rad me or is he having
a cardboard sign well I think it was
through social media where he would
offer his services and then he just
started becoming like a buzz like people
started following his pictures and all
that yeah because he documents all of
his experiences on his Twitter any
interesting hire him out one day to hold
all your shopping bags when you shop
carry all your groceries this guy's a
really hard worker yeah a really hard
worker be happier now than like
yeah he says he's like way happier now
he has a worldwide family cuz you know
what's funny is when he had a place he
couldn't was he not paying around or he
was just being a lazy ass and not huge
was really sloppy stuff messy he was
being around but he couldn't find a job
right yeah this would be a very good
YouTube channel just random odd jobs
every day and he just brings his family
along to watch that'd be dope I can't
live like that though but man good for
this guy alright welcome dude no matter
what even if this guy's quote-unquote
considered homeless he's still Japanese
oh he's hard-working as [ __ ] he's
camping almost Japanese man I only saw
it coming anyway
I saw some I saw some but they never
bothered I saw a couple on a you know
like a bridge pass yeah and then right
next to it there's like a slanted piece
of cement or whatever it knows these two
guys chilling on cardboard boxes talking
to each other at all with the wise
bearded [ __ ] I didn't the only time I
ever saw anyone was that night we went
out to try to get a massage and we ended
up going to McDonald's as a really long
oh yeah yeah that was still the best
massage in the world yeah I couldn't get
one oh they're pretty good this is
pretty interesting that's why I was
thinking like this could only work in
Japan
yeah I don't think it could really work
anymore cuz people here will just hire
you and make you do terrible things or
like a skater like run these drugs for
me I'm gonna punch that old lady in the
face or something that's true we have a
different culture he looks like a
showers and looks clean yeah he looks
clean for a homeless guy haha flip-flops
and socks I like this guy yeah I think
he's definitely having a lot of fun
yep that's my dude right there but he's
homeless by choice he's kind of doing
this as an adventure he's not someone
who's really down and out yeah this is
very fulfilling for him probably looks
like he knows how to eat - a part of me
wants then part of me just wants to
travel for like four months and then
just [ __ ] do whatever she ate what
the [ __ ] did I turn Mexican like [ __ ]
lay you know like experience [ __ ] and
party
I'm right there with you but something
is kind of like telling me I don't
deserve it yet it's not the fact that I
don't deserve it yet is more along the
lines of I'm gonna be really poor so
you're talking about if you're traveling
you're not doing any business emails
you're not calling you're not a [ __ ]
sucky all that [ __ ] in dude just
internal [ __ ] cells about body I only
see articles of people like I sold
everything I have in a work random odd
jobs around the world now I travel the
world but the grand naman definitely I
don't know I can do that man
this older killing at the church they
used to go to another kid is able to use
convict James he to you he's a I don't
know what you call the structural
engineer or something whatever it's like
a form of like architecture or whatever
I'm [ __ ] dumb either way he quit his
job he saved up for enough money for
tutors where he could travel and do
whatever and he went to almost I would
say almost every country based it like
over 20-something countries or something
and he said the his favorite place that
he went to was actually New Zealand yeah
he came back super dark but he said that
there's like these off islands that you
could actually go and rent out with
people and you just
island like like small little islands or
something like that you could rent it
out with people for X amount of fee and
he said he would just wake up in the
morning on the beach do whatever and he
loved it it was pretty crazy I don't
know if I could that for two years but
you know okay
age Amalia people from New Zealand can
you confirm that because I'm remembering
this as a person at the age of like 19
or 20 so I couldn't know if Jamali was
an island and we needed to execute
someone what is going on here I'm just
saying no one can if we needed someone
yeah yeah we could throw them in the
ocean that's no we swimming like well we
will bring us a boat with a floating
hey that Scot we kill them bug him I
hope you guys enjoyed this video for
more please subscribe to our Channel and
you can check out the last video right
here
[Music]